poèmes poèmes
la bougie bouge à bourges le caillou
cale à caen et pour conclure je voudrais
mais mais mais mais mais mais ne veut
pas m'aimer
la main à marigny
est à la traîne elle est dans ses petits
souliers
beni hammad marieu et sourire
quand elle frissonne sous la pluie
sous la pluie
péché de chair flaque de sang
la mal mariée à 17 ans
dans ses yeux je vois des bateaux qui
coule qui goût des larmes
la mal mariée
et en heure
il existe et qui se passait être nulle
part on peut être seul au milieu d'une
foule aussi bien que devenue déserte
c'est ce qu'il fallait dire c'est pas un
peu je pousse maboul
maintenant ça ça dépend des gens il ya
des gens qui ont besoin de voyager
géographiquement donc besoin d'aller à
milan
saibou un chandail
hamon hôpitaux a demandé partout alors
que lisons que moi je voyage plutôt à
l'intérieur ça se passe là je suis un
pessimiste ou optimiste c'est pas je me
tape sur les cuisses jamais ça je vais
avoir pas sans mal
ça n'existe pas la folie pour assumer je
crois qu'en fait les fous sont partout
sauf au il y en a très peu dans les
asiles en fait ils sont les en dehors
les fous j'suis pas moi il me semble que
des gens comme comme les généraux sont
des fous si j'envoie les autres un peu à
l'abattoir jour ça c'est des fous
dangereux sont politiques des fois sont
des fous dangereux
je vais un peu passif quoi résistance
facile à dire l'homme assis est un peu
passif moi je pense que c'est à dire je
trouve pas un point suffisant et une
barre pour renverser le monde je sais
pas je suis déjà ça gentiment vendée
avant tout ça il ya eu
il ya eu l'école primaire la maire fin
la maternelle et le primaire
je lycée clemenceau à nantes où j'étais
interne pendant ce temps par la chine
et puis après je suis rentré en faculté
j'ai passé propédeutique de marché
devenu chanteur bonnes intentions des
chauffe eau par par vocation
au départ on n'a rien demandé vous voilà
comme ça sur le quai d'une gare puis on
fait avec
voilà enfin la vie c'est choquant la vie
c'est formidable on pas c'est qu'on vous
impose son bas villach quand elle fit la
connaissance d'un homme l'est dont les
mollets vif et quelques avance minimale
car je suis en otage plus de tours plus
d'autocars que du brouillard encore
le coup de rein le sac à vin
d'importance celle à melay dont les
molaires
te donne de l'importance est le suivi
passé minuit dans la chambre
223 mais oui c'est ça mais où sont les
toits mais où sont les mots tant elle
défile à
son bas filés et le rex tout
ce soldat ou civil et ville élèves il
enfila centre à son enfant dans son
bidon son beau fils a quant elle fila
connaissance d'un homme l'est dont les
me laisse plus fine quelques avancées
mais que fait d'elle que fait la dame
hortense elle compte les poils du mollet
ça n'a plus d'importance mais ça n'a
plus d'importance
je pense au japon c'est un moyen vous
être un peu plus facile de gagner de
l'argent d'être intégré dans ce système
puisque système il ya le système c'est
nous
c'est quoi l'argent pour vous cela
moyens d'être 4 euros l'once cette
incroyable payer mon loyer eau gaz ou
d'électricité
c'est fait l'arrière
je tiens pas non plus être le plus riche
du cimetière vous finissez ma chanteur
marginal ont obtenu vous n'êtes pas
forcément dans le courant de la mode ça
veut dire martin
je sais pas prévient que le marketing
vis-à-vis de certaines clientèles si tu
bouges de la gauche en général mais je
sais pas très bien ce que ça veut dire
marginal qualifier
j'essaye plutôt être un chanteur j or
alors je vais dire original plutôt que
marginal et le show-business tel qu'il
est fait actuellement un style vue
satisfait pleinement
moi je sais pas on va pas demander mon
avis je suis arrivé c'était déjà en
place s'est pas créé d'absence
événements et voie d'une maison de
disques les bastidiens mais j'ai pas
m'en plaindre non plus tout témoin
mon cas personnel je veux dire je suis
pas prêt à en publier le chanteur
méconnu
la chanson fait pas que chanter en marge
il avait toujours un peu mon pari en
reste un je trouve pas ça forcément
craquer comme pensée oui tout le temps
on est tous dans le bo
la roue tourne la roue tourne
vous voyez aussi beaucoup de mots crus
tout de même nom aussi aussi oui moi je
crois qu'il faut pas être hypocrite
vis-à-vis des mots sont des mots qui
existent je vois pas pourquoi on s'en
servirait pas l'attendre heureusement
tout ça parce que vous la face et moi je
crois qu'elle savait les mots crus
souvent on dit race et vulgaire oh tu
sais c'est pas la vulgarité c'est pas ce
n'est pas une affaire de moore je crois
qu'on peut être vulgaire on peut être
vulgaire avec des mots
outre est choisi
et l'amour est important
euh oui oui bon c'est très important il
faut baiser
allons-y
e
maman mouche cousue place dans ces
tissus de shell
et nous on s'habitue à mâcher le cul nu
que mon père nous a faits dans le doubs
par derrière avant de nous laisser
tomber tant chez touché plein le cul du
petit frère torché tort chez ma mère
balayé la misère
maman bouche cousue taillé dans ses
tissus de chaîne
son salaire de misère pour élever mes
frères ont cédé spectacle parce que
pouvait pas envoyer de problèmes de
communication avec le visage en tout
alors on fait du spectacle pour
communiquer avec les gens là on
communique sur j'aime
mais en fait cette arme tout comme une
quinzaine et tamas de malentendus et en
fait on communique pas vraiment avec les
gens c'est juste dans l'espace
spectacle dans la durée d'un spectacle
et après c'est là où on ressent un
solitude profonde qui nous envahissent
après le spectacle et police dfjp à
l'hôtel